what's up
guys bang bang lunch money
time well while she's trying to get rich
dresses trying to get a bunch of money
right i'm here
with the lumberjack pelina marinova
pompliano i could cut down some trees
right now you ain't cutting nothing down
we can be sure of that all right don't
forget that block fire is now the
sponsor of lunch money go and get an
interest bearing account earn up to 8.6
percent
epy in those interest bearing accounts
block fight.com
pom you can also buy and sell crypto you
can give them crypto and take out a us
dollar loan
it's awesome it's like a wealth
management
platform for crypto investors everybody
knows
bitcoiners are right fiat currency is
just a religion
and is going to end
at some point so go get an account
blockfly.com
pomp what's up let's go one
standard bank sorry standard chartered
bank analyst warns that the greenback
ik aka the dollar is vulnerable to a
significant depreciation as sovereign
fundamentals appear to be pointing
south you have the twin deficits in the
u.s getting worse you have the trade
balance at the worst in 15 years
said eric robertson global head of
research at standard
chartered bank election day is less than
two weeks away
he said that former a victory for former
vice president joe biden would mean
uh any dollar depreciation is set to be
very clear and very pronounced
if trump is re-elected he said that it
will be a little bit more messy in the
short term
what do we think holding dollars only
going one direction
it's like a sinking ship and if you want
to be the captain that goes down with
the ship that's fine
it ain't gonna be me nope the dollar's
gonna get weakened because they're gonna
keep printing money they've already
printed three trillion dollars the fed's
balance sheets increased by 75
this year they're gonna probably bring
another two billion dollars or so to the
market
for a total of five they also ran a
three trillion dollar deficit last year
which means the only way to go ahead and
pay for
all of this stupid debt literally 20
something trillion dollars worth of
national debt is to continue to devalue
the dollar and to use cheap currency in
the future to pay off the debt
going to be the most obvious trade in
history why is it obvious i got it here
first
i've been i've been saying it for two
years now three years now i don't like
how this camera is like this
well sorry it makes me look like i got
chicken chin
go ahead what's next billionaire hedge
fund manager paul
tudor jones reiterating his love for
bitcoin
he said he has turned even more bullish
on on bitcoin calling it the best
inflation hedge
i like bitcoin even more now than i did
then i think we're in the first
inning of bitcoin and it's gotta why do
i keep wanting bitcoin
bitcoin and it's got a long way to go he
said
uh he first revealed his bitcoin
investment in may said he holds a small
single digit investment in bitcoin um
i i like that he said it feels like um
he said
bitcoin has this enormous contingency of
really really smart sophisticated people
who believe in it
it's like investing with steve jobs and
apple or investing in google early
wow that's big for ptj technology gets
issued in
uh ushered in by those who are willing
to bear the flag
never forget that and there's no
technology in the world that's got more
flag bearers than bitcoin
i guys i watch this video of this girl
doing a hula hoop dance to bitcoin
there's some weird flag bearers out
there but they're out there
get your flags and let's go all right
what's next this is turning into a
bitcoin commercial no
okay quibby shutting down
i don't want to say it but in january i
wrote an article that said
i'm a millennial and i don't get it and
i don't think it's going to work but
good for them if they have all this
money like i really hope it works out
for them
it hasn't worked out for them quibby is
shutting down barely six months after
going live
um jeff katzenberg has been unsuccessful
in his talks for getting it acquired he
tried to sell
the library it didn't work and
he in an open letter he said our failure
was not for a lack of trying
we've considered and exhausted every
option available for us
i have two thoughts one i never want to
discourage anyone
from starting companies and for trying
this is the whole bedrock of americans
supremacy in the world is that we
encourage capitalism
innovation nobody is discouraging and
it's just they racist
no people are mocking it they're saying
you guys are stupid all this kind of
stuff they don't think they were stupid
they're saying the idea was not really
great
but i bet that somebody builds this and
it ends up being super successful maybe
but now is not the right time for this
because millennials aren't like the
the people they were targeting were not
the right people and it was not the
right product for those people
again they didn't have product market
fit which is what linda just described
but this idea will be successful
i actually believe it was the wrong team
yeah and maybe it wasn't the right
people to build it
because these people
were arrogant very arrogant that's what
it came down
to the arrogance killed them and
nobody's talking about that because
nobody likes to have that conversation
but the arrogance of raising two billion
dollars before you have a product in the
market
is appalling it's shame on the investors
for giving it to them
and then on top of that if you look at
it from the sense of
there are uh interviews that jeffrey
katzenberg gave
where people were saying well we've
talked to like some people in your
target demo and they don't seem to think
this is going to work
and he basically was like he said sorry
i've been [ __ ] doing this for
longer than you've been alive you can't
talk to the people you're targeting that
way
and also it doesn't matter and by the
way
no you haven't you've never built a
technology platform
he met he knows what high quality
content is and maybe it was high quality
content but
if you don't have the distribution if
you don't have enough people watching it
it doesn't matter
arrogance can kill anything all right
next next tesla
oh my god tesla shares jumped five
percent after reporting
fifth consecutive quarter of profits
yeah tesla's doing well tesla went
through a
i think it was a five to one uh stock
split recently
that's why it's up no
it was the way stock split works
stock went up oh guys yawn oh that's
just sean
cool stock goes up
and they say hey for every five shares
you have
uh or i'm sorry for every one share you
have now you're gonna get five but it's
at a lower price
and so that's a way to keep the stock
price lower uh so more people can buy it
and uh when they did that it's already
running again
and so this is gonna turn out to be one
of the greatest
trades uh this year and uh kathy wood
is gonna end up being very smart very
right you know what i think like for all
the people who are like oh elon musk
whatever
do you know why i uh believe that
tesla's going to be successful oh shoot
no she's not at tesla
gwen shot well she's at a spacesuit
spacex
i'm bullish on that company because of
gwen and also elon but
mainly tesla is a category defining
company
obviously electric vehicles are going to
be the future anybody who says
differently
is an idiot or just buys okay what's
next
okay let's not get crazy well it's just
a fact all right do you think that
electric vehicles are
the future yeah okay there's
legitimately people on wall street who
are arguing that tesla's not going to
succeed because electric vehicles aren't
going to be a thing
idiots okay we're seeing the big
auto companies also trying to move to
electric so like that argument doesn't
hold up
um next you know purdue pharma
they basically fueled the opioid crisis
they're the company
that makes oxycontin and
now it has agreed to plead guilty to
three
federal criminal charges for its role in
the opioid crisis
pay more than eight billion dollars it's
a historic
pharma settlement and it's going to shut
down the company
and there's a family behind it called
the sacklers
and there's a great profile on the
sacklers in esquire called the secret of
family making billions from the opioid
crisis a few years old but it's still
really good
if you want to check it out what do we
think do you want my actual thoughts and
the family is
under criminal investigation as well
it's not just the company that's getting
the brunt of it do you want my actual
thoughts
like my true thoughts yes these people
are scumbags
that's my actual legal drug dealers yeah
they're just drug dealers
like you're literally just a drug dealer
here's my here's why and i i never
never use the word scumbag unless i
really mean it
the three worst things that you can tell
somebody is that they're a fool
they're silly or they're a scumbag and
they're scumbags you know why they're
scumbags it's because they knew what
they were doing
it's not like oh we're selling um
you know something and it's supposed to
help people and then all of a sudden
we find out later that it was killing
people and we stop
that's not what happened here what
happened here was
they knew that the opioid crisis was
real they knew that they were killing
people
and they hid all kinds of information
from doctors
and then they went around and they
financially incentivized doctors
to prescribe this stuff for people who
didn't need it
that's why they're scumbags and on top
of that i've never said this publicly
i had the opportunity to take money oh i
remember
from the sackler family and literally
the person who brought me the
opportunity
he didn't even finish the sentence and i
said i don't take blood money
that's my that's that's how serious i
take this
i don't think that these are good people
and i don't think that these people
should be allowed to operate businesses
that eventually lead to people dying
and now the us government agrees with
that and
they agree with it because they pled
guilty and they're gonna pay eight
billion dollars
the fine should be a hundred billion
dollars not eight because they still
profited off this
even with the eight billion dollar fine
and now they have to shut down the
company
but what instead should happen is the
federal government
should go in and say you committed a
crime
and all of your assets are derived
from those criminal proceeds so what do
they do
there should be people who go to jail
they broke the law
right we need law to be enforced
they also should have a situation
where this is prevented in the future i
want to make one
clarification there are people in this
family who have nothing to do
with the business who have no say they
were just
born randomly into a family same sackler
or they were carried into or they
married into it whatever i'm not talking
about those people those people
it's not their fault they had no uh
involvement they had no anything
i'm specifically talking about the
people
who went to work every day and
facilitated this bad behavior
they've admitted their guilt they
admitted that they're guilty
they've admitted that they committed
crimes we should punish them to the
fullest extent of the law
because this is scumbag stuff so several
state attorneys
uh attorney generals who signed uh
this letter were quickly quick to
criticize the deal
uh one connecticut's attorney general
william tong said
the settlement provides a mere mirage of
justice for the victims of purdue's
cause misconduct
the federal government had the power
here to put the sacklers in jail and
they didn't
and said they took fines and penalties
that purdue likely will never fully pay
i mean just drug dealers with cologne
it's all they are well if you read that
profile it's very interesting because um
there was a very uh intentional
decision to not make it uh you know the
sackler
named the company after the sacklers it
was purdue pharma it wasn't sackler
pharma
every time they have one role where uh
they are asked about the family the
source of the family wealth
they do not comment yeah they they
either don't comment or they hide it
these people know what they're doing is
a bad thing they're embarrassed by it
there's nothing worth worse than doing
things
that you aren't even willing to own up
to or admit
to people if somebody says hey how did
you make your money
and you did something that you're not
proud of saying
wait tells you everything you need to do
let me ask you this so when the con
the company was operational and they saw
it was like ravaging
you know west virginia and all these all
these states
what what could they have done just shut
it down like what what
stop giving drugs to people that don't
need it
yeah but it isn't but then there's the
the doctor layer and then there's the
they went and they told doctors
information that was inaccurate and they
also financially incentivized
the doctors in all kinds of different
ways but ultimately their financial
incentives
to suggest uh to um prescribe this
medicine over others
this is a criminal organization that's
what this ultimately is
they broke the law they systematically
profited from doing that that's why they
admitted guilt
all right go ahead i enjoyed this rant i
i just
there's two things that pissed me off in
this world and one of them
is literally when people intentionally
take advantage of other people
and especially when they profit off of
killing people sorry
just just one small the other thing is
when dominoes is out of pepperoni pizza
one small aside i in the years that i
have known anthony he
never says a bad word about people even
when i'm like oh that person he's like
eh you don't know
so he never actively talks behind
people's back if he has a problem with
you he will
tell you to your face which i appreciate
about it but i had never seen this in
action until one day we were at this
conference and somebody was trying to do
some sketchy stuff with his company
and the the beast that was unleashed
anthony was like you are acting you know
you're misleading people you're doing it
i would shut it all down shut it all
down like there's no way in good faith
you can continue to run this business
and that guy was like oh no no no what i
told him
is it i know exactly what you're trying
to do here it's a scam and if you launch
this i'm gonna call you out on it
publicly
that's what is he launching no
okay ready the former chief executive i
like people by the way
i i really do it's just some people are
just bad people man go ahead
and you'll call them out yeah look i'll
just call spades babe you're awesome
i'll be like you're awesome if you suck
you suck yeah but he'll never talk about
you behind your back oh no you'll know
how i feel about you
i need to say the name but i'll just say
right to your face go ahead the former
chief executive of uber
travis kalanick has been quietly
assembling a mini real estate empire
over the past two years
and he just he just spent more than 130
million
dollars on property acquisitions for his
ghost kitchen startup
cloud kitchens what do we think
listen innovators are going to innovate
i think this is a good idea for a
company
this is going to be a home run home run
tk
for the second grand slam of his career
yeah the acquisitions are a big bet on
the fast growing food delivery business
delivery only kitchens has been around
for years and have raised hundreds of
millions of dollars from venture
investors hoping to replicate success
of the co-working industry et cetera et
cetera i just think winter is coming
things in new york are going to shut
down again restaurants will probably
shut down again
and we're gonna have to rely on these um
on delivery yeah i mean look
this is super smart he knows what he's
doing it's gonna work
next ready for my joke so readers are
readers
viewers people friends
if you think my jokes are bad or if you
just want to contribute a joke
you know my sense of humor send it to me
comment
or tweet at me i will see it yesterday
someone named
quarantined spanish escape
at stan can you say it again no man i
just the fact that they got you to say
that is that's the joke that was great
okay i don't know what his name is but i
think it's something spam maybe
um he said here's a joke for lunch money
tomorrow did you see it
no i didn't why do millennials always
hang out in groups of three
five or seven
because they literally can't even
ah quarantine stanimal you get it
i got it it wasn't funny but you liked
it great name bad joke
all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling
in the comments and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends